how would you rate the president on a
scale of one to ten Champion best
I would say probably a zero really and
why is that well I I judge him by his
own campaign
um uh promises he was going to build a
wall with Mexico that they would pay for
that's not happening it's not going to
happen he was going to repeal and
replace Obamacare with something better
three proposals to replace it all would
have led to 15 to 23 million people
ending up without care but all of those
failed to pass another big campaign
promise he said he would do it right
away failed to do it he said he was
going to renegotiate trade deals still
hasn't done that he also said he was
going to pass a tax cut Bill not looking
good the Senate now in a whole bunch of
trouble trying to figure out well how do
we do this it's going to explode the
deficit we're not going to be able to
go back to our constituents and explain
to them why did we vote to explode the
deficit so I mean I think by his own
standards he's accomplished none of the
things he promised to accomplish